my mother was a teacher and a town
councillor
she had undiagnosed autism and add as
many women her age do and essentially
she just had
a nervous breakdown um she now really
struggles to
talk to large groups of people be in
busy situations and sometimes even leave
the house
so how did you at the age of 10 start to
help her start to
care for her
you just you just pitch in because it's
your family and you love them whatever
happens
uh i'll never forget the day that i
realized that my mother wasn't
necessarily
well anymore um luckily um i just got
back from primary school
and um we had a letter or something
financial it was a long time ago and she
just started rocking and
she wouldn't respond to me and luckily
my grandparents were um
well my grandfather was alive and able
to come and help so i took my brother to
the shop
and um yeah but you just pitch in
you do whatever you can and as i've
grown older um as i've
matured i've worked out how to help more
how to help less and how the whole
family can come together and support
each other
it's i mean it is it is remarkable any
time that i've ever spoken to someone
who's been in the position that you're
in
starting caring for a pen at the age
that you have i'm just i'm just
overwhelmed with respect
for someone but but but but at the age
of 10 to be confronted
not just with a parent's ill health but
with a parent's collapse to the point
where where you have to
start parenting what what effect did
that have on you
it's made me who i am um i love my
mother i love my family
and i don't think i'd change it um there
were financial situations that sure
i'd have loved to go on that school trip
etc but
i am who i am today uh i consider myself
incredibly resilient um not i say
resilient not stubborn in job interviews
um and ultimately
it's showed me how lucky i am to have
the family around me
because we all support each other
it is remarkable to hear you say that
but i suspect that a couple of moments
you know you
there will be of things that you may
well have missed out you know uh
opportunities for nights out with
friends and family that that might not
have
might not have happened but even at
those kind of moments where you you kind
of may be second guessing yourself
just from what you've been saying it
strikes me that even even at those
points your mum remained your
overwhelming priority
yeah definitely um even even if we go
uh i'm at university now so it's very
easy to go sometimes without talking to
her if she's really upset me i can
i can help her without um having to talk
to her sometimes
but i i still love her a lot um and
i would drop everything if she needed me
to and when she does
um i will because um
it's it's not she hasn't failed me at
all it's
the support and the lack of support that
we've got given as a family
that's that's failed us um but you take
what you're given
and i'm proud of our family and who i am
i mean you say you you take what you're
given by what you're saying it doesn't
sound like
you were given particularly much
this is i think this is true um we all
have privilege and we all have areas
where we don't have privilege
i'm lucky enough that my mother has
always prioritized my education
um and that has allowed me
to get to where i am i'm a phd student
um
how many young carers get to that point
i don't know
but i'm very aware that uh we've taken
the best from a bad situation um
and i have my mother to probably
sacrifice
her ever getting better again for that
um
so you know she's given me as much as
i've given her definitely
just to say to say that again so you for
in pursuit i mean
it is remarkable that you're pursuing a
doctorate it really is remarkable that
you'll be able to pursue a doctorate but
but kind of the cost to both of you is
perhaps your mom not getting
back to where she where she once was
um well we're not sure if she ever would
have got better but
unfortunately due to the lack of support
um as well as the the simple fact that
you have to prioritize things my mother
prioritized my education um
it is she will never work again that is
for sure she retired at the age of
i want to say 41 um
and yeah she will never work again i'm
very aware that
when my grandmother goes who is a huge
support of
um all of us we all support each other
so when she had her hip replacements i
helped her and things like that
um when my grandmother goes i will
probably have to drop everything and
and help her out but uh she's letting me
do
what i want to do as much as she can
so covered 19 has made everything more
difficult and i can imagine
particularly for someone in your
circumstances i'm just wondering you
know
how are you doing this morning
i'm all right i have a lot on um i i
work a lot to try and help make sure
that i have six jobs for example most of
them they're all part-time so
of varying levels of commitment um and
i'm
first thing i woke up was going what am
i going to do after this how what do i
need to do
um but i'm all right and i i feel like
we're reaching
the light at the end of the tunnel to
use a very overused phrase
but i think it is appropriate and i'm
looking forward to seeing my mom again
because it's been a while um i
i'm not a hugging person but i'm looking
forward to hugging her